>> Christina Barron:
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the National
Book Festival.
My name is Christina Barron.
I'm the KidsPost editor
at the Washington Post,
one of the charter
sponsors of this event.
I want to thank Festival
co-chairman, David Rubenstein,
and the other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in the program.
We may have time
for a few questions
at the end of this presentation.
I've been asked to remind
you that if you come
up to the microphones
here, you will be included
in the videotape of this event,
which may be broadcast
at a later date.
Now, I'd like to welcome
Katherine Applegate back
to the book festival.
She was here in 2013, which
was a very big year for her.
Katherine won the Newbery
Medal, the top prize
in children's literature
that year,
for "The One and Only Ivan."
[ Applause ]
It was a novel based on
a real silverback gorilla
who spent 27 years
confined to a shopping mall.
She let Ivan narrate the story
and helped readers consider
what an animal might think
about its own captivity.
The book has captivated
millions of kids and adults,
not by preaching about cruelty,
but by creating a
story that's also
about unexpected friendships,
courage, and self-discovery.
Since then, Katherine has
woven other important issues
into compelling stories
with unusual characters.
She tackled homelessness with
the help of an oversized,
imaginary cat in "Crenshaw."
A gentle, red oak was
at the center of a story
about racism in "Wishtree."
And this year came the
first book in a trilogy
about a species so
close to extinction
that it's believed
there's only one left.
In "Endling: The Last," we meet
Byx, an animal called a dairne.
Dairnes look like dogs,
but they stand upright,
have fingers, and a pouch.
They can talk and glide
like flying squirrels.
Pretty cool, right?
But dairnes aren't the only
species Katherine dreamed
up for Endling.
When the book landed on my
desk, I saw this adorable,
big-eared creature on the cover,
you probably can't see it,
and thought it has huge
ears, thought was it that.
And as I dove into the
world of dairnes, wobbyxs,
and other fascinating animals,
I realized Katherine had created
yet another story that would
enthrall, as well as educate.
I happily included it in
this year's KidsPost summer
book club.
I look forward to finding out
where the story goes from here.
"Endling: The First" will be out
next spring and the final book,
"Endling: The Only," in 2020.
I'm delighted Katherine is here
to share more about Endling.
Please welcome Katherine
Applegate.
[ Applause ]
>> Katherine Applegate:
I'm so excited to be here.
I used to live in
Alexandria and Annapolis.
And I have family
all over Virginia.
So it's kind of like
coming home.
The humidity, immediately,
I knew what I was getting
into because I live
in California now,
and we don't have humidity.
We have earthquakes,
mudslides, and fires instead.
But it's so cool
to see all of you.
And I'm really excited, and
I'm going to talk really fast
because I have a
lot to show you.
I'm going to start by
telling you a secret.
Now when I do this at schools,
I ask the adults to
cover their ears.
And invariably, I get maybe
50% compliance because,
you know, teachers.
But I'm going to try it here.
Okay. Grown-ups,
cover your ears.
Kids, here we go.
This is my terrible secret.
When I was your age, I really,
really, really hated to read.
And I know I'm not
supposed to say that.
And most of the writers
you're going to talk to or see
or have sign your books,
they loved reading.
I mean, they were reading in
the womb, and they reading
with a flashlight
under the covers.
They love, love,
love, love to read.
I just kind of thought
it was boring.
And now I have a
daughter who has dyslexia,
which makes it very
challenging to read.
Although, with good teachers,
you can really overcome it.
But that wasn't my problem.
I just kind of didn't
get the point.
And then, I found my book.
And some of you may
have read this book,
and you may think it's
your book, but no,
this book is my book,
"Charlotte's Web."
And for me, that was
lightning going off.
That was doors opening.
It was everything I ever wanted.
It was a perfect book.
It was a perfect book for me.
But you know what?
There may not be a lot
"Charlotte's Web"
enthusiasm in your soul.
You may be somebody who
loves graphic novels,
or maybe you love nonfiction,
or maybe you love poetry.
It doesn't matter.
There's a book out there
that is going to be
like your very best friend
in the whole wide world,
like it was written just
for you and you and you.
And when you find it, you
are going to be a happy --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Wow. So you made the cut.
Way to go!
I guess they're saying there
are so many people here today.
That is really amazing.
I love seeing that
many booklovers
in one giant place like this.
And I wasn't always
a book lover,
nor was I always a reader.
This is my official
author photo.
You will notice I am, in fact,
wearing pajamas and surrounded
by tons of -- That's
not toilet paper.
That's crumpled paper.
And the reason is I
always show this to kids
because I want you
to know one thing.
This is the only thing you
have to remember, okay.
Writing is about
making mistakes.
So when you try to write your
stories, be prepared to fail.
You are going to
fail magnificently,
and you're going to
fail a lot, okay.
It's about making mistakes.
It turns out, interestingly
enough,
life is about making
mistakes, too.
It took me a while
to figure that out.
But it's fun once you
realize that if you write,
you are going to rewrite.
Now I realized something.
Tell me, somebody, does
that cat look happy to you,
just out of curiosity?
Wouldn't you say made?
I looked all over the
Internet for a mad picture.
And somehow, to me, this
was perfect, a wet cat.
I write better books
when I'm made.
And it took me a
while to realize that.
I've written a lot of books.
I mean, I wrote Disney books
and Little Mermaid 17 Sweet
Valley Twins for certain people
of a certain age
in this audience.
Yes. Thank you, Jessica,
Elizabeth.
And I found that when I was
mad, I wrote better books.
I wrote "Home of
the Brave," which is
about a Sudanese refugee
who comes to our country,
because I was mad
about the way refugees
and immigrants were
being treated.
I think it's an amazing
thing to come to this country
and start from scratch.
I think it's an amazingly
brave thing.
I write -- I like you guys.
I wrote Ivan because I was
mad about this little guy.
That's Ivan on the left
and Burma, his twin sister,
on the right, plucked from
the Democratic Republic
of the Congo, shipped off to, of
all places, Tacoma, Washington.
The very top there where
it says world famous,
that's a picture of Ivan.
Ivan lived for 27
years in a mall alone
because his sister died
almost immediately.
And that story just freaked
me out and made me mad,
and I thought nobody on Earth
is going to want to read a book
from the point of view of
a gorilla, but I'm going
to tell it anyway
because I'm mad.
I wrote "Crenshaw" because I was
upset about the fact that one
in five kids in our
country hungry sometimes.
And it's very much a book
about hunger and homelessness,
but it's also about a
great big invisible cat
because I just thought
that'd be really cool.
Also, if you haven't seen,
there's an old Jimmy
Stewart movie called Harvey,
which was the catalyst for this.
It's absolutely where
I got the idea.
It's very old and very black
and white, but it's hilarious.
And that's where I got
the idea for "Crenshaw."
I wrote "Wishtree" during
the throes of the election.
And there was a whole lot
of red and gluing going on
and a whole lot of meanness
and a whole lot of vitriol
and a whole lot of othering
of entire groups of people.
And I was so mad that I
wrote this book really fast
and with great ferocity,
although it's a very,
very gentle book because I
wanted it to be for young,
young kids so they could
understand what racism is about,
what unkindness was about.
So I decided to tell it from
the point of view of a red oak,
a POV I had never attempted,
had some difficulties
because it turns out, trees
don't move around a whole lot.
So that assemblage of
animals helped out.
And it really helped
me because I wrote
about a little girl named
Samara, Muslim girl,
who moves in next to this tree,
and someone carves the word
"leave," l-e-a-v-e,
into red spark.
It's a hate crime.
And the tree decides to
do something about it.
So what I've discovered is
that books build bridges.
And how does that happen?
It happens because we're
in somebody else's head
or maybe some tree's head
or some guerrilla's head.
And all of a sudden, you're
thinking in a different way,
and we call that empathy,
which is just a very fancy way
of saying imagining
with your heart.
After I wrote "Home of
the Brave," some kids
in Massachusetts
experienced empathy,
imagined with their hearts,
and raised enough money
for this young man,
whose name is Qual,
to go back to Sudan
and find his brother.
He was a lost boy.
After I wrote "Crenshaw" or Ivan
rather, hundreds of schools,
I mean, this is really
impressive,
have adopted gorillas
through various programs
like the Dian Fossey fund and
sponsored this incredibly rare
and vanishing species.
Another side benefit of
having written Ivan is
that it's turning into a movie.
And it should be out I think,
don't quote me, next summer.
I went to London recently and
got to watch them filming it.
It has the coolest cast.
It's going to be CG
live-action hybrid.
So Angelina Jolie is in
it and Bryan Cranston.
Helen Mirren plays a poodle.
Danny DeVito plays Bob the dog.
It's just the coolest thing.
And that would never have
happened had I not written
the book.
That little girl, you
may recognize her.
She was in a Disney show
called Stuck in the Middle.
Her name's Ariana Greenblatt.
And she is playing Julia.
After I wrote "Crenshaw,"
there were lots and lots
of nationwide food drives and
were continuing to do that,
and that has been
credibly gratifying.
Excuse me, water.
I also have rediscovered my
allergies since returning here.
Excuse me.
I shall talk quietly.
I'm I wrote "Wishtree," people
started making wish trees.
Wish trees are actually
very common.
They're all over the world.
You'd tie your wishes
onto the branches.
So this is an outdoor version.
This is an indoor version.
This is just magnificent.
But they're all beautiful.
And people put their
wishes on them.
I love this one: I wish there
would be no more bullying
in the world.
And this one: I wish that
hugs could solve everything.
I think we all wish that.
But this is one of my favorites.
This was an adult.
She was at a book convention.
You guys are all going to be
making this same wish by the end
of the day I guarantee you.
So when I talk to kids, I
often have them make a wish
for themselves and a
wish for someone else
and a wish for the world.
And it helps you think about
other people in a whole new way.
By the way, I'm going
to be signing later,
I think 3:30 to 4:30.
And I have these, I
have about a hundred
of them, these window clings.
They're beautiful.
They look like that.
And you can put them on your
school window or wherever.
And I'm happy to give them away.
So feel free to grab one.
So that brings me to Endling.
And I wrote Endling because
I was mad about this.
Endling is not a word you'll
yet find in most dictionaries.
A couple are starting to use it.
It was recently employed
because we are seeing what a lot
of people are calling the
sixth great extinction.
We are losing massive
quantities of species.
And this time, it
appears to be man-made.
Sorry.
Okay. It appears to be man-made.
And endling is a word that
refers to the last animal.
Oh, gah, this is
going to be good, huh?
I've never done this before.
It's really weird.
It refers to the last animal, or
it could be any kind of species,
but it's the very last
individual in a species.
And we have a lot of
those, unfortunately.
Now I had written
fantasy before,
including a series
called Animorphs,
which has like 63 books, with
my husband, Michael Grant.
And we created some really
weird species, including yeerks.
They're little slugs that climb
into your ear and kind of eat
out brain and take over.
So I knew all about
making species.
But I decided with Endling,
I was going to do
something really interesting.
I love dogs.
So I decided to create
the perfect dog.
The perfect dog is Byx.
Byx is a dairne,
sort of a Labrador.
She can walk upright.
She has a pouch because,
you know,
it's easier than
having a backpack.
She walks, has fingers,
opposable thumbs,
very useful in an adventure.
And she can glide like
a flying squirrel.
I created Tobble
who was a wobbyx.
I used a fennec fox.
Have you ever seen a fennec fox?
They are so adorable.
Only I made her bigger,
made him bigger.
Giant ears, blue-gray fur,
really cute, great big eyes,
and incredibly feisty
when needs be.
Now a lot of times when
I do school visits --
A lot of times when
You're just going
to have to come back
in an hour [inaudible].
Geez Louise.
Cough drop may be good.
A lot of times what I do
is I have kids make their
own species.
This is so fun because
you can take anything.
Ask yourself, what would
my species look like,
what would they eat, who
would their enemy be.
It's really fun.
Do they have giant ears?
Can they fly?
Can they swim?
Can they do both?
Can they talk?
Do they have a religion?
Do they have a philosophy?
It is so much fun.
And a lot of times at schools,
I'll have kids come
up with three traits.
And they'll tell me, and
they are always the coolest
of cool species.
You also, of course,
need to make a map.
Where is that going to be?
Could be anywhere.
Could be on Earth.
Could be a whole
different place.
And unique characters.
I decided to have a couple
humans because what the heck.
They're brave and
they're kind of fun.
I decided to have
interesting home life.
That's a [inaudible] bear hive.
I decided to have
many adventures,
including giant serpents.
Byx attends her own funeral.
She meets up with giant raptors.
And most interesting, I
gave Byx the ability to tell
when people are lying.
I have a question for you.
If you could have
the ability to tell
when your friends were lying
to you, would you like that?
Raise your hand if you
think that's a cool idea.
Pretty good turnout.
Okay. Now, let me ask you this.
If your parents had
the ability to tell
when you were lying,
would you like that?
No. That is why Byx is both very
valuable and very dangerous.
Now I talked about being
mad like a wet cat.
Well, endangered
animals make me mad.
And here are just a few of
them: tigers, whooping cranes,
blue whale, Asian elephants,
sea otter, orangutans, gorillas,
Eastern and Western
gorillas, red wolf.
So what can you do?
Well, a lot of things,
and some of it starts
with politics when
you get older.
But meantime, some of it has
to do with climate change.
There are a whole lot of
reasons we're losing animals.
And one of the things you can
do is turn off your lights.
You can recycle.
You can pick up trash.
You can unplug electronics.
I'm really bad at that.
You can use both sides of paper.
You can take shorter showers.
You can volunteer
in your community.
I like this one,
become an expert.
Pick a species.
And it doesn't have
to be a cute, cuddly,
adorable baby mountain gorilla.
It can be anything you want
and become an expert on it.
When you do that, you
see success stories.
Manatees are coming back.
Trumpeter swans are coming back.
Bald eagles are coming back.
So there is hope.
Now, it's your turn
to take over.
I want you guys to get mad.
Think about something
that really makes you mad,
build some bridges, and
you become our next heroes.
Now we have time for
just a few questions
because I busy choking.
Sorry about that.
Does anybody want
to ask anything?
It can be about anything.
I try to pretend I'm a gorilla
expert, but I'm really not.
Yeah.
Technology.
It's wonderful when it works.
You want to yell?
You could just yell.
>> What made you
want to write Ivan?
>> Katherine Applegate:
You know what?
I saw that story, and I was
made, but I was also fascinated.
How would a gorilla
survive living as a human?
And he did.
Do you know he lived
in a kid's house,
slept with a 10-year-old
boy for about two years?
And he would open the
refrigerator and watch TV,
and he liked cartoons, and
he ate all kinds of candy.
And they would hold out his
lower lip and pour sodas in.
Ivan lived like a
human for a long time.
And I just thought that
would be a fascinating story.
>> Do you have any advice about
writing from the perspective
of a suffering animal?
>> Katherine Applegate:
You sound like a writer.
I hope you are.
You know what you do?
You kind of forget who
you are for a while,
and you do a lot of research.
Research is fun,
and it's a great way
to procrastinate, by the way.
And you find out everything
you can about the senses
of that animal and the
needs of that animal.
And that's how you do it.
Sorry.
I think we have time
for about two more.
>> Hi. I'm a school librarian
from Montgomery County,
Maryland.
I just spent my preservice
week building a wish tree
in the hallway.
Thank you for answering
my Tweet the other day.
And I wanted to tell you that
we're beginning our school year
with a schoolwide
read-aloud of this book.
And each student will
be creating wishes
and hopefully turning them into
goals for their school year.
We're going to use it
with our social-emotional
learning components.
So I just wanted to share that
with you and how excited we are
to welcome Red and all of
his friends into our school.
>> Katherine Applegate:
That is so lovely.
It's been the kind of book
that people seem to be able
to connect with at
different levels.
In fact, they're releasing
it as an adult novel.
And what I think is great is
I don't care how young you are
or how old you are, we all
have things we wish for.
We all have hopes and dreams.
And I think Red is just a way
to help us think about that.
So thank you.
You know, that book, no
book would get anywhere
without school librarians.
You guys are our heroes.
[ Applause ]
Okay. We have one more
minute for one more question.
>> What book do you think
would give the most impact
on a national perspective?
>> Katherine Applegate:
Could you, I'm sorry,
repeat the end of that?
The most impact?
>> On a national perspective.
>> Katherine Applegate: Wow.
You mean of mine?
>> Yeah.
>> Katherine Applegate: Well,
I like to think that's
even possible.
You know, I think every
book is different.
So a book that might
matter to a whole bunch
of people is wonderful.
But if one person, I don't
know, "Home of the Brave"
and it meant something to them.
I had a woman write
-- She's a woman now.
She was a girl when she came
over as an African refugee.
And her letter was
short and sweet.
And it said, you wrote my life.
And that, to me, you know --
If she had been the only person
who ever read that book,
that would have been enough.
So thank you all so much.
What a glorious audience.
You've just been
absolutely wonderful.
Give yourselves a round
of applause [applause].